oh baby all right let's [ __ ] get into
it where's chrissie at
it's not my real name
did you put on the email chrissy
my name's dimitri but i emailed chrissy
gmail.com all right let's try to have it
accurate okay my real name is gerard all
right you actually walked into your
apartment like you chrissy yeah
you emailed us an hour ago
let me do a little background check the
big name give it to him yeah what the
[ __ ] this guy's suspect as it is
all right you got a captain america
t-shirt on that strike one right there
what's the credit score like not good
okay here we go
here we go
here we go what'd you get on your sats
uh i didn't even take them my man all
right here we go
we're [ __ ] three for three ladies and
gentlemen look at him
you ever been on the local news
all right fair enough you ruined that
thank you
let's go all right chris quit is it
garbage to fake a stomach ache ex wait
hold on let's start over
there's a lot of twists and turns
is it garbage to fake a stomach ache at
school multiple times simply because the
school nurse never wore a bra
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] dude
how many times we talking
once a
that's the nurse
he was in there staring at me like i was
the piece of me you believe this little
pervert
here you want to see him
what grade are we talking about
huh
oh that's prime age yeah
you must have been busted on the inside
jesus christ i got a tummy ache and a
huge boner what do i do
start with the boner i'm hard as a rock
guy dammit
what was her name you remember her name
i don't remember
[Applause]
give him a last name something
give him something to play with do it
thank you we have this
i meant last name too when you become an
idiot who's your middle name
i just better generally
well
in his defense he did struggle with his
own name so
he's not great with names let's give him
that he's still thinking about it he's
rock hard right now
one time for chris c everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
your wife your girlfriend very
nice together
very normal that's real josh
it was an all-green wedding
cinco de mayo two years running
now you guys live together
you own your own place are you ready
very nice congratulations for them
that's awesome
kind of credit score you see me you got
your [ __ ] together
[Applause]
all right okay good luck with the house
not approved
what you have for breakfast this morning
i'm over here trying to talk you up man
four gravity balls fat boy
who says a big bowl of marijuana
big bowl of enjoying life brother
some world's problems trickle away
play off the reefer you might get the
house
where are the keys at dude
dude where's my house
bank took it because you're high
dude
[Applause]
he goes that's funny thanks
have you seen the show
that's trademark are you garbage bingo i
don't get the ideas
i'll stick the suits on
all right michael's question is do you
know anyone that thinks teriyaki is a
type of animal you can eat
the teriyaki was spotted in the wild
savaging a wolverine
who was it just a squirrel with a stick
in his ass
that deserves way better
hold on big man what did you say
your 25 year old brother thought
teriyaki was an animal
how does he explain teriyaki chicken
there
it's a crossbreed yeah
they make it in a lab i'm telling you
that's insane it's like the pink man
from years ago
it's like a turkey tuna everybody knows
that
holy [ __ ] that's trashy that sucks
that's awesome part of your bloodline
clap it up on time for mike everybody